jenny starts off this hour in charlotte
north carolina hi jenny how are you
hi gentlemen i'm honored to speak with
you both thanks so much for taking my
call
our pleasure how can we help well i want
to tell you dave your new website is
fantastic so
good job whoever you hired it's amazing
thank you for a great one
our in-house team did that and i will
give them a
give them a high five from you thank you
great
my question um i've been a stay-at-home
mom for almost five years now my husband
and i have a two-year-old and a
five-year-old i'm a five-year-old
and my husband is a controller down here
and he makes about 170
and he he i would call him a very very
loyal
person employee he has great integrity
he's just
amazing and he um his job as a
controller down here his
his company keeps acquiring other
companies
and when he took the job five years ago
they've warned him hey the books are a
mess
um you know you're gonna stumble into a
lot of problems and this is just what
keeps happening with this company
and as they keep acquiring more
companies they're buying companies that
have
the books that are a mess i'm not an
accountant so i don't know anything
about that
um however he just recently recently
received a hundred and forty thousand
dollar bonus it was two weeks ago
and we have been looking at already
moving to different states
he's been looking at other jobs and now
it's kind of he's in the
debacle of well i just received this
huge bonus am i going to look like
you know not loyal just like a you know
a not great
employee not a great person if i take
this bonus and leave or shall he
wait it out a little bit longer would
just love your opinion
from both you gentlemen and what you
think what a fabulous question
yeah that's great so you've
hired and fired more people than i have
i'm i'm thinking through
my thoughts on that what do you think
dave i i really like your husband
um loyalty is um
a type of integrity a piece of integrity
that is
uh a vast wasteland land in our culture
it doesn't exist
very real doesn't exist so um i i really
appreciate him being
what i would call old school in that
regard
and um uh but i do not think that
the uh i think he's been paid and
bonused
for work that he has done not work that
he's going to do
and so i don't think he's doing anything
morally wrong
or even violating loyalty um
i'm trying to reverse the shoes for a
second and say gosh if i was his
leader and we just gave him a hundred
and forty thousand dollar bonus on 170
000
income
i would appreciate not getting noticed
two weeks later
uh that would feel a little icky uh
if the roles were reversed right uh but
also i don't expect someone
uh to uh to stay here
when uh when it's their time to go
um you can you know we tell people all
the time you can not work here and go to
heaven
and so um you know it's you it's this is
not uh
it's not the only place to work it's a
great place to work but it's not the
only place to work and
so sometimes people's season their
they they run through their uh the
energy that they had for the cause
uh i'm not leaving but other people have
and so i've you know come to accept that
so i i
i would think some amount of a little
bit of time i mean he was you weren't
gonna give notice next week anyway you
still haven't found a job you don't know
where you're going but if you leave in
the next six months
i don't think you've done anything wrong
six minutes you didn't do anything wrong
but it just feels icky you know what i'm
saying
it's not cool yeah huh yeah
john what are you thinking yeah i'm
really wrestling with this one dave
because
i'm trying to think if i gave someone
140 000
like this is me being transparent i
think in some way i would be attempting
to
pay them for work done and by their
continued loyalty
and i think that's a bad motivator yeah
i mean um
you know and the same thing could just
be saying if i pay somebody a huge
income
right but i don't want someone
especially someone i'm paying a huge
income too
right to be here and not be happy
yeah be miserable their time is done
um you know it's bad enough if you're
paying somebody
a little bit of income in there that way
but it's really bad if you're paying
them a lot of money and their heart has
left
so we always tell people you know when
your heart leaves a building take your
butt with it
yeah hey jenny so is he just tired of
the constant acquisitions is he is is he
is it a toxic work culture where people
are not cool to him and then they just
will throw money at him
the people the people that um he works
for oh the bosses are my age they're 35
years old and they've just
built up this amazing company and
they're they're amazing people there's
no toxicity at all it's just
every company they acquire they're
getting it on a deal and so
here you go cpa controller just work
with these messed up
accounting books but i don't know like i
said i don't know anything about
accounting
and it just keeps piling and piling but
he well
you know
yeah here's a suggestion you know number
one uh what controllers are supposed to
do is control
that's why we call them that and so
they're supposed to clean up messed up
books
that's that's what he says that's what
he's if he goes to another company
uh i mean there are very few companies
that do a wonderful job with accounting
most of them do an okay job or a really
bad job
uh and depending on the size of the
company the sophistication of the
company and so forth but um
you know we have stellar accounting
another issue
but but i think i think he might ask for
some help i think he might be
overwhelmed
yeah that's that's my thought two little
other pieces
they've hired a couple people to work
under them to work under him but then he
ends up training all the people which is
great though because he trains them
the way that you know uh he likes
they're gonna work
yeah right so he loves that but then
also he's not in charge of any decision
too so i think and five he said five
years i'm putting in the work and
we can wait longer it was just kind of a
bummer because i mean
you know what i think i think the bonus
what is he looking for
in the new job there you go that's
different
and i would go in and ask for that here
because i think he's got a pretty good
gig yeah because
and i'm basing that the big thing you
said is these are good guys
oh they're awesome yeah and if you go in
and go listen
i'm frustrated by this and this
and in order for me to feel lo think
longer term about this whole thing
i need to i need some help with you
adjusting those things
yeah i need some control i need to be
able to make some decisions here i need
to be able to do this and
i need to be able to implement this and
you're you know you're giving me all the
work but not the authority to get it
done
you're delegating the responsibility but
not the authority that's a breakdown in
basic leadership skills
whatever it is but i think you could
probably come out these guys and
reset your job and it might be the best
job you find because it sounds like they
love you
and you don't dislike them right very
cool conversation
i used to get 140 000 bonus i'm just
saying dave